[Music]
hello and welcome to this special panel
discussion from the spectator sponsored
by netwealth the investment advisory
company i'm fraser nelson editor of the
spectator we're just a week on from the
chancellor's budget which gave us the
highest tax burden in 71 years and quite
a few surprises mainly the kind of
volatility and how different the
economic outlook is now from what it was
just a few months ago the true test for
richardson act will be in the coming few
years but and while the global economy
is now going in all kinds of directions
it's not clear at all what the future
might hold is this now the time to
invest in the stock market is this now
the time to get out with a number of fan
managers suspecting expecting a
significant crash within the next few
years um a month's even and so where do
we go from here
i'm delighted to be joined by gerald
lyons who is a former economic advisor
to boris johnson and also economic
advisors net wealth and luis cooper
independent financial commentator who
many of you will know from the
spectators pages so i'd like to start
off gerald by um just asking you how you
see the broader economic outlook right
now because after the pandemic it wasn't
sure if we were going to fall off a
cliff if we're going to come booming
back in a v-shaped recovery or somewhere
in between what's it looking like well
first and foremost it's great to be here
so good evening
maybe sort of three key messages to sort
of kick off the evening first in the
very near term i think one should be
wary of the outlook in the sense that
there's going to be considerable
uncertainty and therefore in terms of
the markets a lot of volatility at the
moment markets are really impacted by a
combination of factors health and
geopolitics have the possibility of
resulting in extreme outcomes but apart
from those the markets are very much
focused on the economic data and the
policy outlook and in terms of your
question
over the last six months we've seen a
complete evolution in the market six
months ago markets were focused on
strong recovery rebound with policy
really helping then we saw a move
towards a greater concern about
inflation and more recently the concern
has been not so much about inflation or
the strong growth but more about a
deceleration in activity america's lost
momentum china's in the growth recession
so in the very first key message is
near-term uncertainty undoubtedly but
the second message is despite despite
and despite all that be very positive
about the longer-term outlook the world
economy has a lot of positive underlying
drivers challenge for us in western
europe including the uk is many of these
drivers are likely to be more positive
for other parts of the world so we need
to really reposition ourselves to sort
of benefit from this so the indo-pacific
is emerging as the strong growth region
of the globe economy pacific just to be
clear from india in the west to america
in the east so we're talking india china
asia basically or all of that that side
of the world absolutely and then on top
of the indo-pacific being the growth
region the other key underlying dynamic
and certainly evident before the
pandemic and likely to be so now is the
digital and data revolution so companies
here in the uk and indeed in the west
can still benefit from that so first
message is near-term uncertainty second
despite all that lots of positivity in
my view the indo-pacific and the digital
data revolution but the third coming
back to your question about the outlook
uk assets are undervalued but the reason
for that is partly because there is a
lot of uncertainty about uk growth
prospects and what we really need to
have here is a pro-growth economic
strategy and the government basically
outlining the sense of direction and
direction of travel so the economic tax
rate in 71 years would you describe that
as a pro-growth strategy um no
but
the high tax rate needs to give way to a
low tax rate in the future
we can talk maybe i don't want to take
up all the time here but i think there's
lots of areas we in terms of the uk at
net wealth i argue that we need to have
a
three arrowed pro growth strategy one is
monetary and financial stability and at
the moment in my view the bank of
england is neither on top of monetary
nor financial stability second arrow is
credible fiscal activism which means
reducing debt to gdp over time
and not through higher taxes or spending
cuts because that's like being in the
hole and digging deeper but getting debt
down by growing the economy and the
third aspect is the whole supply side
all the eyes investment innovation
infrastructure and incentives which
coming back to your question phrase are
incentives to get the economy going need
smarter lower regulation and smarter
lower taxes well if you're still boris
johnson's economic advisor imagine you'd
be having to resign right now i can't
see him taking much of that advice but
let's continue that later louise um tell
us how you see things are you as
optimistic as as gerald here so i take a
very long-term perspective when it comes
to investing by long-term i mean
definitely
decades yeah decades right so i'm 51
maybe i might live until i'm 80. um
historically you make money in the stock
markets by looking long long term you
don't make money by trying to time a
market i get in this month i get out
next month i buy this six months and
then i sell in six months that's not how
you make money trying to time a market
oh it looks expensive let's sell a bit
oh it looks cheap let's buy a bit is
utterly impossible almost no one can do
it many will pretend they can but they
can't so you need to have a very
long-term perspective so let me just
give you we've had two
economic crises in what just over a
decade that's pretty extraordinary to
start with we have the global financial
crisis and now we have the economic
crisis and the pandemic in the global
economic crisis in 2008 uh just a little
bit of history lesson uh the s p 500 in
the states lost 37 percent it lost a
third of its money in a year everyone
was like oh no scary times actually that
was the most fantastic buying
opportunity because the s p has gone up
over 600 since let's look at the
beginnings of the pandemic end of 2019
beginning of 2020. global stock markets
in crisis in in chaos fear drove the
markets the s p fell 20 30 percent the
foot seat fell 20 30
again fantastic buying opportunity when
everybody else is fearful that is the
time to be greedy so stock markets you
look for the long term you don't try to
time it in and out um that's not how the
the markets work and the data jared will
back me up here the data proves that
right so generally speaking you're
saying you're optimistic you're saying
it doesn't matter if you're optimistic
pessimistic because in two or three
decades and that's your sort of
five years like you cannot it is true
the us stock market is over expense is
expensive it's true the uk stock market
is really quite cheap but a us ever
since i've been in the markets and i go
back not possibly quite a long as long
as gerard but almost i go back to 1992
when i started as a broker at goldman
and we had a very famous strategist
called abby cohen and she kept saying
buy the us market every year 92 93 and i
do oh it's expensive it's expensive it's
expensive
yeah you know
you know you can't be out of a market
just because it's expensive okay but
let's talk about perhaps the biggest
risk factor in everybody's minds right
now and that's inflation inflation is
something we have not seen for some
years um i remember um roger brittle
describing the end of inflation as if it
was now and but what we're seeing now is
that in the space of just a few months
half there but and and then now we're
looking at um
the last one shows four percent and it
might even be higher than that some
people are talking about six percent now
if they can get it so wrong in the space
of a few months what might look like in
a few more months and if there is
inflation then what do you do what can
one do to protect one's assets against
it i mean the ftse is still pretty
buoyant having recovered from its slump
by the way i think everybody was amazed
at how quickly stocks recovered even
before the pandemic was over the market
seemed to think well
the vaccine's going to come along we're
going to get out of this and then
typically after pandemics or after
similar disruptions it's a good time to
invest but right now you're saying
louise the american market's about as
expensive as it was any time since the
beginning of a dot-com crash so if
inflation does come along then what
happens do stocks go up or do they go
down
well before you actually answer that you
need to actually understand what type of
inflationary problem we currently have
and that's the key issue
when you were saying about the opr's
forecast in fact they should have known
better the reality but the interesting
thing is that we know from the past that
when inflationary pressures change
relative to expectations the market is
normally on the back foot in the early
90s for instance we moved from high to
low inflation and the markets were
really slow to adjust they didn't
realize the emergence of china and
globalization was going to change the
inflation outlook so the markets then
kept thinking oh the dipping inflation
is going to be reversed
the opposite happened in the early 70s
then the markets were caught unawares
when inflation really took off so that's
the challenge at the moment if inflation
really starts to pick up then it's
likely that the markets will be lagging
not leading so the question is what type
of inflation problem do we have and i
tend to say which p is it is it going to
pass through quickly is it going to
persist or is it going to become
permanent now the central banks
including our own bank of england say
it's not going to be permanent they
think it's transitory i think they're
right partly because of globalization
and the factors we've touched on the
challenge though is they all think they
the central banks think it's going to
pass through quickly and i think they're
wrong it's going to persist persist for
a year or two in part because we have
lux lacks monetary policy and in part
because some of the factors that have
contributed to this backup inflation are
now allowing people naturally to argue
for higher wages they're allowing
companies to increase their pricing
power build their margins so we've got a
persistence of inflation so in that
environment in terms of how markets
react it's not only linked to what type
of inflation we get but the policy
response and if the policy response is
credible and nips inflation in the bud
then markets after the initial
adjustment which might be slightly
painful or volatile will then rebound
the challenge we have at the moment is
the exit strategies from central banks
not just here in the uk but elsewhere
are far from clear and given that they
aren't conveying that sense of being
sort of ahead of the game reading the
road ahead of them that makes the
markets very nervous i'm so you're
talking about one of the bedrocks of the
current instability is not just how we
occur from the pandemic it's what
inflation doesn't also
take the central bank's balance sheets
not just in britain but in europe and
japan they've been all printing money
like um like nobody's business and the
the and the money printers have been on
overtime and when this happened after
the crash
people like me said well there's going
to be big inflation a big price to pay
for this and rpi went up i've now peaked
at five percent think afterwards but cpi
was relatively low there wasn't really
that much of a price so this time around
when then the bank of england and most
central banks looked at it and you can
you can see on the graph here how the
central bank balance sheets have jumped
from about 15 trillion dollars to to
north of 25 trillion dollars well yeah
the cpi the joke used to be that cpi
should be renamed
the china price index as opposed to
being called the consumer price index
such was that disinflationary impact of
china and we've had those global
competitive pressures really
sort of contributing to a low inflation
revenue
yeah that's right and central banks here
you see this really changed in the wake
of the 2008 global financial crisis and
this you argue about this in terms of
inflation the greater worry in my mind
is what this means for financial
stability because when central banks
have interest rates close to zero that
means markets are not pricing for risk
there's this mad search for yield and it
happened before 2008 as well then we had
low interest rates since then we now
have the additional problem central
banks are now the biggest buyers of
government debt here in the uk in the
states and on the continent the central
bank is now the biggest holder of their
respective
national debt or obviously in the
eurozone it's more than one country
so that creates a challenge because it
means that bond yields are not
reflecting true demand and supply
their biggest buyer is a non-commercial
player so what we have here is that
central bank's actions are helping feed
that inflation problem it means there's
a greater danger that inflation instead
of passing through persists but central
bank's actions are creating this
situation where markets for the moment
are benefiting markets are discounting
the good news markets are assuming that
central banks will always tell us what's
going to happen therefore
we can always exit in time but the
challenge is that central bank's actions
both in terms of low rates and buying
government debt or printing money is
creating greater instability so there's
two challenges here not just the
inflation one but the financial
instability one which doesn't mean that
we shouldn't be positive about the
longer term i think we're both in
agreement there are a lot longer term
positive economic drivers but it creates
that additional near-term uncertainty so
louise and this uncertainty isn't the
safest thing to do to basically put your
money in a cash isa at least you know
it's going to be there
so the problem we have as gerard
explained right is we've had pretty much
zero interest rates since the first
crisis since the global financial crisis
so central bank banks cut rates to
effectively zero but we've had
inflationary pressures since then i'm
also slightly more bearish than you on
china because of the frictions on global
trade anyway but i'll come back to that
so essentially what you've had is zero
nominal interest rates and yet you've
had inflation and so let's just look at
that chart that is the cash iso return
in real terms in real terms so in real
terms if you had left your money in a
cash isa since 2008 you would have lost
10 percent of your money in real value
in purchasing power now why would you
ever
leave your money somewhere where you are
effectively
losing purchasing power losing money in
real terms and this is what you have so
we talked about government debt so the
uk government
can borrow 10-year money for ten years
at one percent a year inflation
currently three and a half could get to
four and a half could get to five so
bang in one year i've lost four percent
of the purchasing power of my money why
would i do that germany right we all
know germany's got negative rates
german government can borrow for 10
years doesn't need to pay you any
interest at all german inflation has
reached a 30-year high
for just over four and a half percent
spanish inflation a 30-year high 5.5
these are all you know the latest
figures so why would you ever invest in
a fixed income asset at a bond market
putting your money in savings when it
doesn't even keep up with inflation i
mean this gentleman may prefer blondes
but they definitely don't prefer bonds
did you like that that was pretty good
right yeah so don't put your money in
bonds don't put your money in a in a
cash right what's really interesting i
was going to say is what you can get
inflation protected and inflation i mean
i think of course quarter of uk bonds
linkedin i mean louise is here i guess
what your argument is is back in the day
interest rates would always keep you
ahead of inflation but they don't
anymore you can actually go down so
you're actively losing your money we get
that of course with their answers why
would you purchase it in the first place
it's because i suppose you might think
the downside of inflation would be not
as bad as the potential downside of the
stock market crash it's very interesting
you say that because the catch phrase
immediately after the global financial
crisis i say immediately after it lasted
for a few years was that people were not
looking for a return of
on their capital they were looking for a
return of their capital they were so
they were so cautious they didn't mind
about not getting the return on it but
the graph that was shown on isis is
quite interesting because what's
staggering actually is how many ices are
actually in cash and the challenge is
obviously someone watching this and
they're hearing us talk about near-term
risks the challenge is that people might
think oh i don't want to put it in the
market but the reality and it comes back
to your initial point about timing the
market
the phrase people say is time in the
market i suppose the time timing the
market sounds very difficult to say that
easily so it doesn't get muddled up you
try saying gentlemen
but the reality is that you need to
almost bite the bullet
if you think the markets are about to
crash then obviously you're going to be
cautious but time often shows is that
it's best to actually put your money to
work and think longer term for instance
last april um or yeah april may just
when the markets have crashed what was
the staggering at net wealth we were
very much taking the longer term view
how many people were trying to double
guess that the markets were going to
fall further and further and then the
markets turned around you can get caught
out by trying to micromanage in the very
near term
right but let's zoom out and look at
some of the bigger trends
you were talking about the um the india
pacific region in other words
effectively the asian economy
america america really comes into this
because it's trans-pacific america is
very much looking towards east asia so
it's in geopolitical as well as economic
and financial terms the balance of power
has moved from transatlantic to
trans-pacific and india as well if you
go even further west so to speak
changing your map of the world so india
over to the states and it's really quite
dynamic china
so northeast asia southeast asia as well
as we can certainly see what portion of
the world the economy was occupied by
india's specific region that's something
over the last 20 years we have really
seen an increase in that i guess the
question is is this likely to continue
do we think that asia is the investment
future and if you you might think okay
we don't know the exact moment but you
can choose your geographical region it's
very easy now to go to any fund manager
and think okay i want to i think that
asia is going to have the next decade in
the next two decades people might have
seen these figures saying that by 2050
the gdp of china will be far bigger than
america right now and if you want to
invest until you're 80 years old as
louise is saying certainly for the next
30 years
you might think to yourself well china
is where it's at now you seem of course
you're an advisor to the bank of china
here but
on the other side you've got the china's
demographic kind of death spiral right
now there are real problems here where
it's difficult to look at that country
and think in 20 30 years time they can
have a bit of a worker to pensioner
ratio problem
the government's asking the chinese to
have more kids but don't seem to be
doing it you spoke about a chinese
growth a recession right now in other
words that china's growth is basically
getting a slightly smaller year and year
so can we really be sure of the next 20
years
or rather
how do you think they will sign
comparison to the last 20 years when it
comes to asia's share of economic growth
and where an investor might put his or
her money obviously any investor can
choose a particular country or
particular region if they want to and
good luck to them but i think one needs
to also recognize the global story and
the diversification let me quote three
figures in this context
here in the west we are constantly
pessimistic it seems we're constantly
talking about the problems but three
figures 31 62 102 102. at the beginning
of the century the world economy was
just over 31 trillion dollars in size
the day the financial crisis started the
global economy was up to 62 trillion
dollars in size based on the
international monetary fund's projection
for next year which seems pretty
credible next year the world economy
will be up to 102 trillion dollars in
size the point is that despite all the
challenges the world economy is continue
to get bigger a small amount of that is
inflation the vast part of it is really
economic activity and it's inspiration
and perspiration perspiration is
demographics which in some countries are
dividends some places might be a
disaster if you don't plan for it but
you're right china's growth rate will
slow because its population will age so
china therefore needs to move from the
perspiration to the inspiration part
moving up the value curve in some
respects that's what we need to do as
well here in britain inspiration hence
last week in the budget was all about
science etc
so the combination of factors but when
you put it together the global economy
has done really well despite the
challenges that are hitting certain
parts of it particularly here in the
west but in terms of china yeah its
dynamic is
of slowing it's the second biggest
economy in the world but in terms of
income per head it's way down there 70
or so
the re india is really interesting the
1 in 12 people in the world is an indian
under 27
which is quite dramatic in if india gets
its demographic dividend right then it
suddenly has the ability to propel
itself and if we went back 20 years
india and china both had the same income
behead or just over 20 years ago
india india's still got something like
150 million people in poverty i mean
this is a country which with which is
basically
so many things do you think india is
going to be the next china in the next
20 years china's poverty level went from
i think in the last 20 years from 68
percent to something like 0.8 now and
extreme poverty incredible progress in
the space of just a couple of decades do
you think india is going to do the same
thing um i think india will probably
beat people's expectations but i would
be surprised if it
matches up to how china has done in the
last 20 years but i would be more
positive
than maybe the consensus is about india
but the point is that if the
demographics become a dividend if you
get it right they become a disaster if
you get it wrong but in terms of coming
back to your question about trying to
pick the regions of the world there's no
doubt that when one looks across the
indo-pacific there are parts of that
region where the demographics could be a
real positive but there are also parts
of that region where it's going to be
the inspiration side for instance
india's
size of india's economy
is the same if you take the 10 economies
of southeast asia asean their collective
economy is the same size as india now
that shows that when we look at asia we
often talk about china we don't always
talk about
india we don't talk about southeast asia
south korea many people some people
watch him think india's never going to
do it south korea is a good example in
the
50s south korea was the size of a mid
african state
south korea is now the 12th biggest
economy in the world it obviously got
its policies right
and the private sector came to the fore
but those success stories have been seen
in a number of countries over the last
few decades so one shouldn't always be
too skeptical but
sensibly one shouldn't just assume
everyone is going to do it africa is
really interesting when i was chief
economist and head of research at san
diego i used to go across africa and in
fact i think
we taught it up once i went to 84
countries and business some of them you
would get to you look at the data think
great then you get to one or two
countries and you have this deep intake
of breath and you think how are they
actually going to realize their
potential but often it requires
credible policies real solid politicians
some people do make it some don't but
the point is that you shouldn't
generalize and we need to be quite
selective as well but louise and i guess
if you think that
the future is uncertain you might think
you never know when's up or down time
but you could might think okay do you
invest you look at geographically or do
you think about sectors do you think i
want to go tech sector or the property
sector what's your overall approach
so
um
there's a couple of things right to
always bear in mind an economy is not
the stock market okay so just because an
economy is growing doesn't mean the
stock market will do fantastically we'll
find out whether the shares in that
country are expensive or cheap we're
saying america is expensive no no i mean
the vast majority of an economy comes
from small and medium-sized companies
that aren't quoted in the stock market
so the big thing you need to remember is
the economy is not the stock market okay
so that's the first thing you need to
remember secondly
with china i'm probably not quite as
bullish as you gerrard so there's a few
things that concern me about china so
first of all um
the the rules of the game okay the rules
of the game in china are not the rules
of the game that we play here in the
west so just look at the collapse of the
um major property company i forgot what
it's called now um evergrand that was it
so if you look at that you know there
hasn't been that much detail there
hasn't been
the way a collapse would happen you know
a bankruptcy would happen here in europe
right or in the states so that that
makes me very nervous about going
gung-ho into chinese stock markets and
also when i was improving that's right
sorry yeah and then also when i was um a
stockbroker at goldman all these years
ago
one of the probably the only uk fund
manager that can credibly hold his hand
up and say
he's comparable to warren buffett
anthony bolton from fidelity
astonishing long-term returns over 20 30
years he went to china blew up his
returns why because the rules of the
game are different and if you don't know
how the game is played
it's really best not to try so although
and then there's other issues about
china's economic data we know it's
manipulated we know it's not really
accurately reflecting it and then
there's other issues about the china
having this big boost to growth since
joining the wto there's a whole load of
things that it cannot replicate and so
so
exactly and so that's the other thing
about when you go back to the inflation
and it's going to be transitory right
well
one of the big
things as joe had explained is that
china has exported deflation to the rest
of the world joined the wto and has now
exported deflation there are many
reasons to suggest
that may not happen so
i i mean again so when you look at
inflation i like you have been
predicting we would have inflation for
some time fraser i clearly have been
wrong
everybody always thinks it's going to be
transitory and i am currently thinking
that's why the central bank should be
taken it's interesting your point i
don't know if it's going to be
transitioning i think the key message
i would give to the viewer about china
is that the trend will be up but we
should expect increasing volatility
along the way the real challenge is this
the size of the chinese economy is so
big now and you've touched on the key
point they still they the policy makers
and the government still trying to run
it from the center and it's greater
a challenge to do that so one should
expect greater volatility the trend rate
of growth will slow
i.e will be growing at four percent in
five years time as opposed to ten
percent five years ago the size of the
economy will be bigger but big more
volatility governance as you touched on
is an issue but the interesting thing is
that the chinese are really deepening
and broadening their bond market
so in terms of
financial markets across the globe
investors are looking at the bond market
in china the currency is a different
issue but the challenge of course is
that for all the reasons you've touched
on people don't necessarily want to
necessarily invest in china but they
want to invest in companies that will
benefit from the sort of spin-off shall
we say the global aspects and the
technology side is very much still
driven by america at the moment as well
which is partly why the u.s markets have
done so well we've got quite a few um
questions from our viewers coming in and
and if them
and do you keep sending them in there's
some good ones here um
[Music]
i guess um richard asks what about we're
speaking a lot about basically about
equity funds if that's the only real
option what about alternative
investments i mean commodities for
example should you be thinking in terms
of that if there is going to be this
hunt for resources
right now do you think it's time to
expose oneself to i don't know to to
gold or silver or other such things
well the answer to that is which type of
commodities so in terms of rich's
question i would say that one needs to
differentiate between
the financial commodities the gold
silver shall we say um then there's the
so-called dirty commodities oil related
and then there's the sort of
resource type commodities that are not
dirty but are not financial and the
interesting thing at the moment is of
those people have looked at the gold
aspect and naturally gold has a natural
affinity for some people it's seen as a
safe haven although the safe haven
status is always called into question
but oil all prices are quite um
significant at the moment i use the word
significant again all prices have risen
sharply
yeah and likely to go well above 100 per
barrel i would argue and the green
agenda is vitally important very
sensible to focus on the green agenda
but sometimes when you have people
focusing for all the right reasons on a
certain area there are unintended
consequences and one of the unintended
consequences has been maybe a lack of
investment in some of the fossil fuel
areas which given that we still have a
world economy driven by fossil fuels oil
has not received as much investment
the green agenda which makes it more
politically controversial for our
companies to be drilling for new oil
supplies means there's going to be real
that the demand the supply and demand
ratio
will thanks to the green agenda uh be
skewed in such a ways to make oil a lot
more expensive yeah some people in the
oil industry were saying the very same
thing six months ago when oil prices
were far lower that we have challenges
when one looks
in terms of the green agenda put my cart
on table i've been on the advisory board
of the grant research institute on
climate change in the environment since
it was set up over 10 years ago the good
things now is that people talk about
green going hand in hand with growth
but people almost become too optimistic
about what can be done to move a fossil
fuel economy to net carbon zero by 2050
it's a huge ambition and so still at the
moment base load of fossil fuels is high
base load of renewables is uh low
and therefore as we saw in the last few
months wind production is uh output is
so the point is that coming back to
richard's question commodities yeah
we've seen the
commodities are very much driven by the
cycle as well as by some of these
underlying factors so yes they should be
considered within special thing to do
isn't it i mean is there any is it easy
to do can you buy into an
oil-linked fund or a quantity
yeah
you can always find the specialized
funds at net wealth we focus very much
on sort of being diversified
so
if you wanted to go into specialized
funds yes these are always available i
would caution that the oil price has
gone from 20 to 85 in 18 months the
copper price has soared many of these
commodities have rebounded very strongly
as the global economy has has i mean the
time to buy that would have been 12
months ago not now i mean it's kind of
slightly slightly bubble at the moment
well there is a question to you from
jenny here she's quite struck by what
you're saying about isis and i've got
quite a lot of money in the eyes that
she says should i be taking my money out
immediately uh equity i saw on a cash
isa
so
well no it's the answer if you're money
how why would you actually post a
question why would you want the real
value of your investment to go down ten
percent so so
i just get sorry how how old is she
not the first time
you know i'm judy teasing you gerard so
so it depends on your horizon and it
depends on your
attitude to risk and it depends on your
understanding so i've spent 30 years in
financial markets so i have a very deep
understanding of the risks i'm taking i
understand that long term the s p 500
gives you seven percent a year um
there's a dividend of three to four
percent on the ftse um i you know i
don't i literally do not care
what stock markets do
month by month year by year has no
impact on me whatsoever
but i know that because that's my years
of experience if you're somebody who in
the midst of the global financial crisis
when the s p was down 37 went oh no and
sold your equities or if you were
somebody who in 2019 2020 at the
beginning of the pandemic saw the
footsie crash from 7 000 to 5 000 and go
oh no i need to sell my funds then you
should not be in funds right you should
not be in the stock market if you go the
ftse is down 30 doesn't bother me at all
i'll load them up i'm invested for 30
years i really don't care then
absolutely you should be in the stock
market but the stock market is quite a
psychological thing right you really
should have the knowledge and the you
know i'm very data driven i'm very
analytical i'm very logical so it
doesn't bother me at all but if you're
somebody who's going to be spooked out
of markets and
all the research shows that most retail
investors most people
will look at a collapsing market and
sell what you should do is look at a
collapsing market and go do you know why
it's damn cheap now i should be buying
more but not everybody thinks like that
and in fact most retail investors don't
say for example like um i'd like
interest questions to both of you we're
looking at somebody who's got i don't
know say 10 15 pounds um saved it's a
500 000 saved um off that money what
proportion would you think is safe to
put in equities would you say you're
deaf if you've got london funds
at the moment we both agree the uk stock
market is screamingly cheap but it's
been screamingly cheap for quite a long
time but i'm happy so so
so so what you need is a very
diversified fund so i own uh vanguard
life strategy fund it probably owns
about five thousand six thousand
shares and bonds there you go
that's my vanguard there are several
there are several there's a round of
goat of course a rivalton to net wealth
second biggest fund management in the
world astonishing company big fan right
and they you know
basically saying it's like 20 equities
but you've chosen 80 equities that's
your fund but then i'm punchy i
understand risk right but we can see it
here now so um so then like um if you
look at over the last 10 years it's gone
up by 150
or adjusted for inflation 107 in other
words double g money but that's not bad
um compared to down six percent in real
terms for a um a cash isa so so that's
what that you would have done but then
again so it's very diversified
it's so thousands of stocks not not a
hundred thousands it's diversified
globally so i'm not trying to pick asia
pacific or china or america it's very
diversified globally but it does have a
home country bias i think 40 is in the
uk which i'm kind of happy with because
the uk is very cheap the trouble with
markets is markets can stay cheap for a
long time and they could pay they can
stay expensive for a long time but all i
want is an extremely low cost this is
what most people don't understand you
have to have low fees and i'm paying
about 30 basis points about point three
percent for those funds
every year managers will take point
three percent of your entire portfolio
and charge that as a fund and this is a
metric no no fees are key for long-term
investing because fees compound so
returns compound
fees also compounds so low-cost
heavily diversified globally stocks and
bonds and because i understand risk i'm
more than happy with 80 equity
you should work for net wealth yeah
similar to the story line
but i think it's only fair that as a
sponsor you should talk about this and
net wealth was set up
five years ago relatively young and your
advertising slogan which i've seen quite
a lot in the spectator is that we will
um we will make you a fortune we won't
cost you a fortune yeah um so what is
louise missing here what what what
network one should be investing in
heroes
vanguard's very good actually but it
depends what you're looking for but in
terms of net wealth it you'll give me a
chance to advertise so to speak we would
be offering vanguard plus more we would
be a service so if you want to have low
cost simple investments then certainly
vanguard but you can do that in net
wealth but we're a service as well so if
you want to actually have some advice
about your portfolio if you're coming up
to retirement if you want to pass your
wealth on to the next generation or if
you want to manage your retirement well
if you want to
manage your isa or your pension then we
provide that type of service but one of
the key issues that we do
we actually have very low fees so
relative to the market in the uk we will
probably be saving you just over one
percent per annum so you're right your
point about the compounding so over a
decade we were probably on fees alone
save you about 15
but on top of that you want to be open
and transparent so we have performance
that is always
versus our competitors which is the arc
we aim to outperform by doing as it says
on the tim something simpler so we have
seven sterling portfolios so since its
inception just over five years ago our
portfolio of seven which is primarily
equities
is up 69 and a half percent our
portfolio four is up 44
so but people can see this online if
they want but coming back to the earlier
point is about controlling the
controllables the lady asked the
question about whether she should be in
the cash iso when i said no the point i
was referring to was don't take your
money out of isis because that's one of
your controllables you can minimize the
cash
we we can't predict how the markets are
going to perform but there are certain
things that you can control and that net
wealth we try and argue that
we help you control the controller
boards and so vanguard very good if
you're looking for that
net wealth very good if you're wanting a
service and you want to have vanguard
yes but also you can have more that's
the point right i think we're in this
what the service you're paying for
is
stopping you selling when the market is
crashing or giving you advice as to how
to manage your tax and other issues so
the bulk of our money from clients is in
pensions or isis and that's quite
interesting so the other thing if you
are worried about a topi market and and
to be fair um i'm i'm sure you'd agree
with me there are things that make me
think stock markets are topi
particularly america right the fact that
tesla is now valued at a trillion
dollars right that
so i when i i look at pes of course you
know we look at valuations
but that's the value of the company as a
multiple offer profits yeah exactly so
we look at price earnings ratios right
but i think markets are quite
psychological and so there's things that
you just think um and so the fact that
tesla is valued at a trillion dollars
and there's not many companies value
trillion dollars and if you look at its
sales and profits they barely exist it
really shouldn't be and that makes
something a bit toppy the bitcoin um we
haven't gone there thankfully but the
whole you know but all of that makes
sense the question actually from brendan
this is a fairly standard question here
i mean um brendan's asking do we need to
worry about cryptocurrency do you regard
it as a sort of an extreme high-risk
investment which you should only do
basically it's like akin to gambling
or is it something
well exactly is it gambling or is it an
investment what are your thoughts
coming back to the markets you were
saying a key factor is confidence so any
economy or market is influenced by the
fundamentals policy environment and
confidence comes into play but when one
starts talking about cryptocurrencies
it's more the latter it's that
confidence aspect um i think the whole
backdrop to
cryptocurrencies needs to become far
more developed in terms of what central
banks are going to do in terms of
digital currencies and how that will
affect the whole infrastructure the
whole environment but if you're looking
at cryptocurrencies in isolation just
look at the price movements in the last
few weeks or few months they're
speculative unpredictable and that
suggests that they are not a stable
investment doesn't mean that you can't
make money in them it doesn't mean that
you can't lose many of them but when one
looks at this whole area though there is
a different dimension and that very much
depends on which way i think we're going
to go in terms of digital currencies and
there's a lot going on with central
banks across the globe but if you look
at cryptocurrencies in isolation at this
moment i would be saying look good luck
but don't make that a key part of your
investment make that a sort of small
part and view it as something that
you're prepared to lose
if you go into it okay
so um we've got a question about
retirement given you mentioned it so um
so as rob is saying considering
retirement when should he start to move
away from amid stock investments and
start to look at some other strategies i
mean right now you know you can you can
say if you if you're 25 years old louise
you can think okay i'm going to check
everything in the hierarchy strategy
i'll do it um i'll start to worry about
that in 30 years time but as you
um started to get switching from
equities to bombs yeah
yeah i don't know i'm still pretty
punchy in equities even if i get to get
to an old age to be honest yeah the
traditional view 20 years ago would have
been as you get older put it into bonds
but as you've touched on
but what i would say uh look we have on
unplugging that well but on the website
if you go on and sign up you can
actually go on to this app it's quite
sexy and you can start to put in
your
where you are how much money you have
and then coming back to rob is about
drawdowns it's about how much you want
to draw down each year you can actually
get a profile of how your investment is
going to move and that will give you a
better idea it then allows you to think
ah do i want to have a proportion in
very low risk so risk one or two so it's
a very low return and also have a
proportion in higher risk because i
think the markets look quite attractive
at the moment so the point is that it's
not a hard and fast rule it depends on
your individual circumstances but you
can now thankfully have these apps that
help you guide your decision but it's
not a case of moving everything from
here equities to overhear bonds and that
would be the wrong thing to do now is if
you look at what used to be considered
low risk which is a cash answer yeah
you're saying louise is quite a high
risk because it because it's going down
quite a lot so this sort of changes
people's opinion as to what the
definition is of a safe investment
it's the cost of safety okay that's we
have to bear in mind right
so when the cost was safety that when
the cost of safety was your money kept
up with inflation
that's all right like money keeps up
with inflation that's fine
but you remember you might retire at 65
you may live another 20 years so the
cost of safety if you put into bonds
could be that your purchasing power of
your money goes down 20 percent
the cost of that safety by dumping it
into gilts
is massive so if you're happy to see the
purchasing power of your money go down
by 20 to 30 in your last 20 years of
retirement absolutely put 100 of your
money into bonds but but most people
don't don't want that cost and don't
understand the inflation eroding power
and the compound that sort of minus 10
figure you've shown us
over the case of a decade so most people
don't get that until they're actually in
it and they suddenly go after 10 years
of retirement oh my word i can't afford
my weekly shopping bill
and that's when you understand how
inflation erodes the value of your money
if you are not getting if you're not
even matching inflation and that i'm
afraid the cost of safety is so large
i will be 80 invested into equities
until my dying day if we take this
if we take this i completely agree
actually in terms of how you've
described it but we can take this
further in two different layers here
the first layer is
people's money people have different
financial situations but normally what
people viewing probably have three pots
as we would say pot one is their sort of
cash they're coming in they're liquid
stuff that comes in quickly if they're
pot two is the discretionary wealth that
you can start to come to someone like
net wealth or whoever you choose to go
to and use that to diversify your pot
303 is sort of the fixed bit your house
etc um the fixed or for some people it
might be if they work for a company or
their life it's the shares in that
company the check the next layer though
that becomes the real challenge is
linked to one of your opening comments
about the budget and taxes
um if we don't get the economic growth
we need in the uk
then the challenge is that the
chancellor is going to start coming
looking for it not this chancellor maybe
might be someone else and
wealth is being talked about in terms of
being taxed
in terms of attack global tax system
the things that are mobile are normally
the things most difficult to tax skilled
workers multinational companies although
there's attempts to sort of address that
the things that are not mobile become
the easier things to start to think
about taxing property in particular now
therefore
investors need to be well savers need to
be thinking when they're looking at
pensions not just about their current
discretionary wealth but also
their properties and they need to be
thinking about the tax environment as
well currently controlling the
controllables is managing your tax
liabilities by taking out ices etc but
passing on your wealth if you're in that
lucky enough position is also something
but we now have an additional challenge
the future
wealth tax issue i don't i'm not in
favor of wealth taxes
the thing is wealth taxes are very
difficult to get this question from
yvonne here saying is long-term
investment and property still a good
approach now in property typically it's
been a hedge against inflation and some
people have thought that a lot of people
think their home is their pension are
they going to borrow to the hilt they'll
put it in the stock market there's a put
in the property market and if average
house rises x month more than average
wages but that's a pretty good
investment now you're saying here gerald
first of all watch out for property
taxes by the way the other thing i guess
we have a look at here is the cost of
net zero some people are saying that the
government's going to stop you putting a
house in the market unless you've done
all of these various insulation things
so all of a sudden your house might not
quite be as liquid as
as people first imagined but when it
comes to wealth tax when you look at the
um people talk about this all the time
we hear it believe a party talk about
what tourists talk about it but it tends
not to happen when dennis healey was
chancellor he
tried to do a wealth tax he looked at it
very closely i've agreed with you i
don't think it will happen because it
wasn't practical yeah but what so but
you're talking about it is a risk well
it is a risk and it is a very solid risk
but i think we will avoid it because i
think the economy will start to grow at
a stronger pace and would start to
actually avoid having to go down that
route but coming back to property in a
different aspect there are a number of
countries across the globe that share
the current uk view that property prices
only go in one direction japan used to
think that way and i think property
prices fell for about 21 years nothing
ever goes in one direction right
my parents came from ireland i remember
used to go back to ireland one of the
few years before the property bubble
burst
and you start to see properties
appearing in the middle of west meeting
you think gosh that was a field last
year when i was here probably they took
years before the property market
adjusted same in spain consequence of
the euro system the money goes to the
out to look for a high yield because
there was no currency raised but still
nowhere near the are still below the
peak of the 80's and japan i think it
might be yes um right i'm pretty
first of all we talk um china's growth
as if it's inevitable japan shows us how
that growth can collapse but also people
talk about property as if it's a one-way
bet it's never a one-way bet and i i've
always hated this idea of getting on the
property left though because it conveys
the wrong impression but what you have
in london it is linked to our global-ish
picture as well 20 years ago it used to
be local supply local demand now it's
local supply there might be more of it
but it's global demand so that
international dimension clearly has had
an impact on london it probably will
have an impact on our uh other cities
birmingham and manchester particularly
leveling up takes place but in the uk we
have the additional issues the
globalization aspect
tends to underpin property prices but
that notwithstanding that
this can still change particularly if
the global environment changes or we
decide to tighten up a migration plan
let's look at i mean international air
travel go down a lot globalization world
trade going down i mean we're now are we
lose back into the language of trade
wars people are talking about we might
even get a carbon tax for example a
carbon tax on the border would be pretty
big tax on chinese goods i mean you can
see an environment where the things
apparent for the last 20 years
globalization easy movement of people
goods and labor that moves into a new
period where things are moving a lot
more slowly uh and i predict to you that
the last 20 years might be the best two
decades we're going to see for quite
some time but right now the next things
are going to be a lot more difficult now
um
economically i'm not sure i agree with
that although the build-up of debt
during these two crises is not good for
long-term growth
corporate debt and government debt but
particularly corporate debt so we talk
about the stock market not being
representing the economy so the stock
market is the big companies right who
can take advantage of bond markets where
yields interest rates are very low what
we need to focus a bit more on is the
overall economy small and medium-sized
companies which are clearly heavily
indebted from this crisis probably i
would argue they would still have a bit
of debt overhang from the global
financial crisis and all of that debt
means that their opportunities for
growing are limited if they're having to
pay back the interest on their loans
they can't hire new people they can't
invest and so
i'm still pretty bullish
and particularly for the ftse because
the ftse does not represent the uk
economy but one of the things we saw
lower growth after the global financial
crisis lower gdp growth that was
structurally it's now lower after
america and europe in the uk that the
growth level reduced after the global
financial crisis currently we have loads
of fiscal stimulus
but i do wonder this buildup of
corporate debt and government debt
how much that will slow our future
growth and that is something i have been
pondering is that was that a fair thing
to say jared am i correct to ponder on
that i think you're right i think i'm so
glad you said that
this is a massive question because when
we look at the amount of government
terrorism now it's absolutely
unbelievable isn't it yeah i mean and
right now when in doubt the prime
minister used to advise he just borrows
like there's no tomorrow he borrows like
a drunken keynesian every single time
john maynard keynes was the greatest
economist this country has ever had and
i gave a talk at charleston in the
summer about keynes but keynes actually
would have been worried about the
current situation keynes would have
argued that in good times you actually
run surpluses
no the point is that it's not wrong to
spend in difficult times it's that you
should make yourself in a situation
where you're in a better position to
spend
global public debt is high it's an
all-time high so it's not just the uk
problem which reinforces louisiana let's
look at interest rates sure the debt is
high but let's look at the actual in the
bank whether it's individually or with
the interest you're paying on your
mortgage every month the house prices
are huge but look at the actual cost of
buying that house in other words the
cost of interest payments they're
actually historically quite low quite
affordable the same with the government
sure is borrowing two trillion pounds
but look at the interest payments as a
share of gdp it's pretty low right now
so do we really need to worry as louis
says they're that low because the bank
of england indulges in quantitative
easing
and and lowers the interest rate so
essentially you've got one bit of
government borrowing the other bit of
government's not really part of
government but the other bit of
government say you can borrow really
cheaply if
if we didn't have qe globally i
seriously wonder if the uk government
could borrow at one percent a year
um no yields would be higher it comes
back to the earlier point about uh
central banks have distorted the price
at which governments can borrow but
there's no doubt coming back to your
question that low inflation
low yields and low rates make it easier
to borrow the question is where we go
from here now debt to gdp in the uk
depends which measure you use but let's
use the latest one from last week 98
percent you take out the central bank it
be slightly lower but debt to gdp after
the second world war for an obvious
reason was much much higher 250 to 60
but the point is that you got we in the
uk got before our time but got debt to
gdp down
to roughly 100 percent by the early 60s
it went down even further throughout the
60s but that's because we had economic
growth and coming labor force returning
from fighting the germans there was no
real connection
there is a comparison because the labor
force returned after the war but the
debt kept falling for 25 years the debt
kept falling as proportion gdp because
we kept growing the economy and it comes
back again all of this is predicated on
what happens to economic growth if
economic growth picks up at a more
sustainable pace more rapid pace
then the debt to gdp picture can come
down and you mentioned the global
financial crisis before the global
financial crisis and we don't talk
enough about global financial crisis in
the uk because it's still impacting that
before that our trend rate growth in the
uk was around two and a quarter percent
so that meant the economy would double
in size take out inflation in 32 years
by the time of 2016 so before brexit
referendum first time the b word's been
mentioned tonight but by then but so
nothing to do with brexit the trend rate
of growth was down to roughly 1.3 1.4
and that meant that the uk economy would
take 60 years to double in size so we
haven't really addressed the challenges
from the global financial crisis then
mind the challenges from this pandemic
but if growth doesn't pick up then the
worries about debt come to the fore if
inflation if inflation picks up then
yields and rates pick up and these
problems become very accurate
i'm going to use that i love that but it
doesn't it doesn't rather rain on your
parade because here you are saying how
cheap person is now we should be
investing in domestic stock but look at
the dismal growth rates gerald's talking
about this doesn't make me feel
optimistic the the foot c100 does not
represent the uk economy all right
that's i cannot because stock markets
don't represent situations yeah i mean
that is the something
you said your vanguard your fund that
yourself found off is about 40 percent
invested in the uk which is that won't
just be the 5100 it'll be the all share
okay so again i go back to the ftse 100
gives you three to four percent dividend
yield so even if the ftse goes nowhere
i'm still getting three to four percent
a year if i invested in bond markets i'm
not getting that so three four percent a
year that keeps me up with inflation i'm
happy with that clearly i would like
more and we always want more but again i
don't have a lot of choice in a world
where central banks are manipulating
interest rates so much lower because of
qe you are completely right gerard
because of central banking central
bank's qe
risk and return are priced wrongly and
so therefore it's you know i have no
choice
but to park all my money into equities
if i was getting what used to be uh the
ten-year yield um on gilts was about
five percent three the financial crisis
if i was getting five percent a year
from a guilt i'm pretty happy with that
little bit of inflation covers inflation
a little bit on top bob's your money you
know i'm bob's your uncle i'm happy but
i'm not getting five percent i'm getting
one percent and so it forces you into
equities and i do keep reiterating the
ftse 100 is not or even the footsie or
share is not the uk economy these are
large companies that can borrow cheaply
these aren't the small and medium-sized
companies that make up a lot of our
economy that are so overly indebted at
much higher interest rates okay so going
back to original question then in spite
of all this volatility is now a good
time to invest and effectively louise
you're saying is always a good time to
invest it's always a good time to invest
if you are nervous if it was it jenny
who was asking about her catalysis so
what i do is i invest every month so i
just keep dripping the money in if
you're worried about buying if you're
worried about timing the market wrongly
you just say right i've got and low fees
are keen whether it's vanguard or net
wealth
yeah so you just keep putting your money
in month by month and then if the market
does crash you cannot predict when the
market's going to go up or down the
market does crash or it does war ahead
you're just dripping your money in month
by month so if you are worried about
market timing that's how you do it given
that um you know both of you are talking
about long-term investing but just as a
matter of interest
by this time next year
the chances of some kind of crash
financial crisis what would you say
jared
10 20
um
well yeah exit strategies from current
cheap money
and high debt policies are
sort of a key issue that have to be
taken into account um central banks
people
you've been asking the bank of england
to to not raise rates but tighten its
policies in other words
you want to start
the best way to think of the central
bank is for the last year it's driven a
car with its foot on the accelerator
there's been one warning sign costs
ahead another warning sign inflation
ahead it's gone through and now we're at
the bottom of a steep hill which cost a
living crisis it's deciding to put his
foot on the brake they haven't driven
the car well that's why i would be
concerned we've talked about inflation
but it's also financial stability risks
if you look at where these might come to
the fore is where the central bank might
make a bigger mistake i was chatting to
a guilt trader earlier this week and
there's um
as the central bank should always be
ahead of the curve ahead of what is
happening and there is a definite
feeling that the bank of england
currently has missed inflation is behind
the curve and the credibility of the
bank of england from the perspective of
guilt markets our government debt
markets is is really quite poor at the
moment is that a nice way of saying it i
was at lunch yesterday and someone else
basically said the bank of england is no
longer in the first division of global
central banks because of what's happened
in the last couple years well they might
not be ahead of the curve but jordan
lines let me scoop her both of you i'm
sure are so thank you very much for
joining me this evening and thanks to
all of you as well watching home to ask
those questions and a final thank you to
our sponsors netwealth now if you
enjoyed this semi show from spectator tv
remember you can get more like it on our
spectator tv youtube channel where our
journalists speak to politicians pundits
and experts every single thursday at 6
pm and round up of what's happened that
week and what's happening the next and
also you can subscribe to the spectator
itself at spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash voucher if you go to that
url you'll get a 20 pound amazon voucher
absolutely free thanks for watching and
have a great evening